today on the matt walsh show one of
trump's best achievements as president
just came this week at the very end his
administration's 1776 report offers a
needed
corrective to the anti-american
brainwashing in schools of course the
left is
steaming mad about it as they tend to be
will address their criticisms today also
five headlines including
katie couric is wondering how
conservatives might be deprogrammed
and nancy pelosi discusses the quote
trauma congress suffered during the
riots on january 6. in our daily
cancellation we will cancel
some very bad parenting advice on tick
tock
probably all parenting advice on tick
tock should be canceled all of that and
much more today on the matt walsh show
one of the most important decisions you
can make for yourself and for your
family in 2021 if you're looking for a
new year's resolution
well then here's something to put on
your to-do list and that is
get life insurance um and if it seems
like a daunting task well guess what
policy genius
it's here policy genius can help you
cross it off your list with ease and
this is one you can make that a new
year's resolution
and and knock it out nail it in like
a couple of minutes and uh and then look
at that you've had success for the
entire year
policy genius makes it easy for you to
compare more than 30 top insurers at
once and save over 50
in the process plus there's no hassle
because their license experts work for
you
not for the insurance companies here's
how it works first you head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy units will
compare policies starting at as little
as one dollar a day
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork all the red tape they're
going to take care of all the tough
stuff
all you got to do is just tell them what
kind of plan you want and they're going
to take care of the rest it's so easy to
do
this kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star
rating across over 1600 reviews on
trustpilot and google
well-earned rating and if you want to
see why everybody loves
pile xenius then just go to
policygenius.com yourself
and check it out and get your family
protected
this year make it the year you finally
cross life insurance off your list and
get protection for your loved ones go to
policygenius.com and get started
you could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes and start
the new year with one less thing to
worry about policy genius when it comes
to insurance it's nice to get it right
a few months ago president trump
announced that he was forming the 1776
commission to counter the
anti-american anti-truth indoctrination
in our schools and other institutions
the focus was especially on debunking
the noxious
lies told to the public and in
particular our children
by proponents of critical race theory
and the 1619 project and similar
things ultimately the the commission's
goal was to offer a corrective to
leftist historical revisionism and to
promote as trump calls it
patriotic education now to my mind this
is not only a noble endeavor but perhaps
one of the most important things trump
has done
with his presidency any attempt to
reverse the cultural tide must begin by
addressing the fundamental sickness in
our education system entire generations
are being trained from the youngest ages
to
hate their country and if they're white
despise their ancestors and themselves
this is not simply a matter of kids
being brainwashed into
a lack of patriotism at a much deeper
level they're being conditioned to
believe
and build their world view around what
is not true
so i would much rather we call the
corrective truthful education rather
than
patriotic education i'm not going to
quibble much over over
those sorts of details but that's really
what we're talking about here
yesterday the 1776 commission released
released its report
reaffirming the basic truths of
america's founding and offering its
critiques of the
radical leftist version of history the
final product is
about 45 pages long it's well worth the
read and if you take the time to read it
you will already be one step ahead of
most of
the reports critics who do not appear to
have even skimmed the document
before issuing their many denunciations
for example cnn's headline declares
trump administration issues racist
school curriculum report on mlk day
by the way that's a that's not an op-ed
that's their news article
calling it racist the washington post
quotes
outraged historians who are incensed by
the report's quote
outright lies the new york times also
claims that quote historians are quote
deriding it for its
false narratives now a brief sampling of
the post article gives you an idea as to
the general flavor of the criticisms it
says um
quoting now i don't know where to begin
said public historian alexis
coe this report lacked citations or any
indication books were consulted which
explains why it's riddled in
errors distortions and outright lies
cali nicole gross
a history professor at rutgers and emory
universities
and the co-author of a black women's
history of the united states said it was
dusty and dated and the usual dodge on
the long-lasting harmful impacts of
settler
colonialism enslavement jim crow the
oppression of women the plight of queer
people
as the true threat to democracy this
report makes it seem as if
slave-holding uh founding fathers were
abolitionists that americans were the
early beacons of the global abolitionist
movement
that the the demise of slavery in the
united states was inevitable
boston university historian ibram x
kendi tweeted
it's very hard to find anything in here
that stands as a historical claim
whereas the work of a historian
almost everything in it is wrong just as
a matter of fact
said eric rochway
i may sound a little incoherent when
trying to speak of this
because the report itself is not
coherent it's like historical
whack-a-mole
okay you'll notice here as you'll notice
in nearly all the denunciations of the
1776 report that little attempt is made
to engage
with the specific and most essential
historical claims
that it makes we're simply assured that
the report is completely false and
misguided and silly and racist
but nobody issuing these assurances will
bother to explain why that cnn article
that called it racist
at no point in the article did it defend
or justify or explain that
characterization
it just said well it's racist you know
of course it is
in fact the critics say you know the
report isn't just wrong but incoherent
and this causes me to suspect that
perhaps these professional historians
are having trouble with the document
because they're illiterate
which would explain quite a lot about
how history is taught these days
and explain why they by their own
omission cannot seem to understand a
report that lays out its case very
clearly and cogently
you can agree or disagree with what the
report says but any literate person
should at least be able to comprehend
what is being said these historians
can't even do that they say they don't
they
just don't understand it they're
completely confused
mostly it seems that the scholarly
community takes great um
umbridge with the reports section on
slavery that that's that's the part
that's gotten the most attention
which they say dismisses or as
huffington post uh a huffington post
headline claims
justifies the practice of slavery that's
what they're saying they're saying that
the report justifies slavery defends it
so let's read what it actually says on
the subject hopefully you'll find this
at least coherent i mean you tell me if
you can at a minimum understand what's
being said
okay this is quote now from the 1776
commission report the most common charge
leveled against the founders and hence
against our country itself is that they
were hypocrites who didn't believe in
their stated principles and therefore
the country they built on rests on a
they built rests on a lie this charge is
untrue and has done enormous damage
especially in recent years with a
devastating effect on our civic unity
and social fabric
many americans labor under the illusion
that slavery was somehow uniquely
american evil
it is essential to insist at the outset
that the institution be seen in a much
broader perspective
is very hard for people brought up in
the comforts of modern america
in a time in which the media in which
the idea that all human beings have
invaluable in inviolable rights and
inherent dignity is almost taken for
granted to imagine the cruelties and
enormities that were endemic in earlier
times
but the unfortunate fact is that the
institution of slavery has been more the
rule than the exception throughout
history it was the western world's
repudiation of slavery
only just beginning to build at the time
of the american revolution which marked
a dramatic sea change in moral
sensibilities
the american founders were living on the
cusp of this change in a manner that
straddled two worlds
okay did you understand that it seems
coherent
isn't it i had no trouble understanding
the point
it goes on to discuss the attitudes that
the founders had towards slavery some
were against it some were for it
some wrestled with the issue throughout
their lives ultimately of course slavery
was abolished in this country and it
only took america 90 years to do it
america was only a country for 90 years
give or take before slavery was
abolished compare that to the track
record of other
nations some of which have been around
for millennia
and still to this day have not
completely abolished it
right now and when you do that you see
that our country is not guiltless but
its guilt is no greater than most any
other nation on earth and in many cases
it's quite a bit lesser
it may be hard for media people and
scholars to understand the simple but
crucial point being made here
but that's either because they don't
want to understand or they're too stupid
to understand or both
the goal of critical race theory and of
the modern left generally is to saddle
white americans with a special and
lasting guilt
stemming from these historical
injustices and to paint america itself
as uniquely evil and almost singular
singularly responsible for atrocities
like slavery
this is wrong and it matters that it's
wrong
we cannot assess our own history or the
people who comprise it
if we do not have an accurate and a
complete understanding of the context
in which these people lived and acted
so we can quite easily and
self-assuredly sit here right now from
our comfortable position
and condemn men like george washington
thomas jefferson for not being racially
enlightened
enough but but you know to thoughtful
people it should make a difference
that washington and jefferson lived at a
time when almost
nobody on the entire planet was racially
enlightened by our standard stay
slavery was indeed a foregone conclusion
a normal part of life for nearly
everyone everywhere through all of human
history until the last couple of
centuries
we could have an interesting discussion
about why this was the case
how was this the case how is it that the
whole world could have been so blind
to a moral truth that we all now see so
clearly
and when i say we all i mean we in the
west because in other parts of the world
they still don't see it
but we cannot have that discussion if we
insist on absolving
everyone everywhere of guilt except for
white men in north america
the discussion becomes absurd at that
point and pointless
and whatever conclusions you draw will
be false and harmful
they'll be the conclusions of the 1619
project and critical race theory
which the 1776 report rightly condemns
now the report ends with this passage
which i like it says to be an american
means something noble and good it means
treasuring freedom and embracing the
vitality of self-government
we are shaped by the beauty bounty and
wildness of our continent
we are united by the glory of our
history we are distinguished by the
american virtues of openness honesty
optimism determination generosity
confidence kindness hard work courage
and hope
our principles did not create these
virtues but they laid the groundwork for
them to grow and spread and forge
america into the most just and glorious
country in all of human history
admittedly okay
some of that is a matter of opinion i'm
not sure there is any objective
factual measure for the gloriousness of
a country
but it's good for a person to feel this
way about his country
and there is good reason to feel this
way about our country
it's how many other people and many
other countries feel about their
countries
all in all of those countries have their
own troubled histories
their own sins their own guilt many
cases much worse than our own
yet nobody would would would mock or
scold them
the people in those countries for their
patriotism it's only
us we are the only ones the only ones
who are supposed to be ashamed of our
country and its history and as heroes
we are the only ones who are not
supposed to be too enthusiastic in our
patriotism
you know we're supposed to issue a
thousand apologies as a preamble for
every good thing we say about
our country at least that's what they
tell us
at least that's the rules they want to
impose
and we should not listen we should
reject that
absolutely now let's get to our five
headlines
all right um by the way i i just have to
this this is more a question i'm asking
i just have to say this because i don't
know where else to say it
uh but it's something that's really been
it's been a source of great contention
in my home and something we've been
dealing with but
um those robotic vacuums
i don't know if you if you've gotten one
of these things like a roomba the
robotic vacuum
seems like a great idea right you get
the roomba
i think we got a knockoff version maybe
this is the problem but we just got it
and i was very excited about that about
it because the idea is you just put it
on the ground
and you never have to sweep again or
vacuum just does it on its own
you got a robot in your house doing a
chore
it's everyone's dream come true they're
very excited about it but the thing is
useless
it just ambles around on the rug i was
watching it yesterday and it
it was there was a cheerio on the ground
and it navigated around the cheerio like
three times
and i'm just sitting there like get the
cheerio
i'm not gonna bend down and pick it up
i'm too busy for instance i'm sitting
here watching the vacuum cleaner
so what's did we just is do you need a
better brand or what's the deal do these
things actually work
that's my question someone can answer
that for me please um maybe more
important issues to talk about number
one katie couric and bill maher
are um well they're worried about about
uh
about deprogramming republicans you know
because that that's what
that's that's the the project that we're
gonna have to undertake in the years
ahead
um in this this deprogramming because
we're all brainwashed
and uh let's listen to that now it's
really bizarre isn't it when you think
about
how awol so many of these members of
congress have gotten but i also think
some of them are believing
the garbage that they are being fed 24
7.
on the internet by their constituents
and they bought into this big
lie and the question is how are we going
to
really almost de-program these people
who have signed up
for the cult of trump deep program and
she talks about the cult of trump uh of
course we know that she's not
only referring to that when we hear this
from the media they're not they're not
that's they they mean conservatives in
general
now i'd be the first to admit and i've
said many times there is
among there has been in some quarters
uh this is a minority of conservatives
but there has been
among some a a cult-like
um dedication and obsession
a personality cult there's no denying
there has been a personality cult around
donald trump i don't think anyone i
don't think any rational person could
possibly deny that
and i've talked many times about how how
damaging personality cults
are no matter where you find them on the
political spectrum and you find them on
the left and right now
they bother me a lot more on the right
because it's because that's where i
am and i don't like to see that where i
am i don't like to see her so close to
home
uh but we know about the the personality
called around barack obama
the the messianic um
way that he was that he was celebrated
and embraced by the media
so that that is that is an issue but
that's not
what that's not what they're talking
about that's that might be what they're
saying that's not what they really mean
and the point is you know it's it's one
thing
when they talk about conservatives like
we're all a bunch of evil racist bigots
you know that that's troubling enough
especially when these people
seize control of the entire government
as they are about to
uh what's even worse though is when they
talk about us like we're sick
that's what you really have to look out
for if they're just screaming at you
you're a big meanie you're a bigot okay
fine when they start talking to you and
about you like you're sick
and you need to be treated for a disease
like your ideas are a disease
that's that's that's the really
disturbing thing
that's when things can go uh in a very
dystopian direction speaking of which
number two representative steve cohen
has concerns of his own um and he's
worried
that you know basically that the
dc right now is militarized it's under
military occupation
but he's not worried about that he's
worried and said about the race
of some of these uh national guard
guardsmen that are that are there
let's listen to this it was certainly
raised this morning i was reading
about this on the on my twitter account
i guess
and people were reminding the people of
anwar sadat and indira gandhi who were
killed by her own
their own people um you know i was
thinking the guard
is 90 some odd percent i believe
male uh only about
20 percent of white males voted for
bible you got to figure that in the
guard which is predominantly more
conservative and i see that on my social
media we know it
they're probably not more than 25 of the
people that are there protecting us who
voted for biden the other 75
percent are in the class that would be
uh the large class of folks
who might want to uh do something
who might want to do something just what
does that mean i think we all know what
it means
just casually accusing national guard of
being a bunch of
potential assassins uh no big deal
but of course that's what he's focused
on is the the racial makeup
meanwhile there are real criticisms that
you could lob against
the fact that that dc is essentially
under military occupation at present
um now you you remember when in the
midst of the blm riots
and uh finally finally after days of it
there was a response and um
a response that almost met the the
violence coming from the rioters
and the media all day long was was
complaining about it's militarized it's
uh
it's it's overboard yet they seem to
have no problem with this
you know i have friends who are in dc
they send me pictures or talking about
the experience but it's just eerie like
they've never seen anything like this
in any american city least of all
washington dc
so if we're going to be criticizing i
think i think i think that would be the
issue
no matter the race of the people who are
doing the occupying
meanwhile nancy pelosi um was was on
hillary clinton's podcast and i i just
learned that hillary hillary clinton has
a podcast
apparently i don't know who would sit
down and listen
to a hillary clinton podcast
of all things but i guess some people do
at least nancy pelosi does and
she was on the the podcast uh talking
about
many things but really focusing on the
trauma
that uh people in congress suffered on
january 6 during the riots let's listen
to that
i as an american am incredibly grateful
for your steadiness
and your devotion to our democracy
how are you holding up well first let me
just say i was very much looking forward
to being with you the kind words that
you say i accept on behalf of my house
democratic caucus colleagues
they've been so courageous so steadfast
so patriotic so committed
to their oath of office and they said at
that point
that there were storming the capital and
the security just
whisked away but it was stunning
but i know again they are protective and
i thought well okay yeah
i'll go with you because it's your job
to make sure that i do
and i don't want to endanger anybody
else and i'm a target you know
so so when we got in the car i said
where are we going
like to another room no we're going
to an undisclosed location
you know when i hear um talk of the the
trauma that
and they haven't stopped talking about
how traumatic it was for them this whole
experience
but whenever i hear this my mind i go
back to a story that i don't
you may have forgotten about or you may
not have heard at all because it wasn't
exactly something that the mainstream
media was
eager to report but just one example you
know you go back to the riots throughout
the summer and um
so many just just just you have your
pick of the litter you pick so many
examples of traumatic
things that uh that regular american
citizens suffered
and people like nancy pelosi never said
a word about that never spoke a word
about the trauma
of people who live in these cities that
have been racked by by rioting
uh the businesses burned down family
members killed
you know i i don't know the family
members of david dorn for example
nancy pelosi ever say anything about
that the trauma they're suffering
but i go my mind goes back to one
particular incident
um the chicago ronald mcdonald house
cancer center for children during the
rioting in chicago
which there was writing all throughout
the summer right uh during the blm
writing
the cancer center was attacked
by rioters okay yes they attacked a
cancer center for children
and there were kids inside there were
families inside and they were terrified
because they're listening to the windows
being smashed
downstairs now just imagine that for a
second i mean imagine you're a child and
you're sick with cancer and you're
and uh and then you hear this commotion
outside these these unruly crowds
you hear the windows being smashed in
your building imagine you're a parent of
a child
going through that there was one young
child and we talked about this at the
time so maybe if you've been listening
to the if you've been listening to this
show you heard about this at least um
one young child owen believed was his
name two years old fighting stage four
cancer
and he was supposed to go home to sell
it for his birthday party that day
and he couldn't go home he missed his
birthday party now they celebrated it
later but he missed his birthday party
that day
because of the uh because of the writing
outside it was it was unsafe to leave
the building
so i you know i don't know when i think
about trauma
that people suffered emotional trauma
that they suffered during rioting
i am much much more concerned about
those kids
and many other children too affected by
it but even just that one
case i'm more concerned about their
emotional trauma think about the
emotional trauma
they are suffering that's something that
they're going to remember in their
nightmares probably for the rest of
their lives
i i just i'm a lot more concerned about
that than i
am about the the trauma the emotional
trauma of grown adults
powerful people politicians in congress
that's just me i certainly reject the
idea that we're supposed to be
more concerned about that about their
trauma the politicians
and what happened to them was so much
worse
it was it was desecrating sacred ground
and sacred people apparently
i i absolutely reject that
all right number three from variety it
says walt disney frank
capra uh whitney houston billie holiday
johnny cash and alex trebek are among
the entertainment industry
figures who have been added as a
proposed as proposed honorees in the
national garden of american heroes
monument project unveiled by president
donald trump in july
as he began his final 40 hours of
president trump trump issued an
amended executive order monday that
added dozens of names slated to be
honored in the planned
statu uh statuary park so there's all
kinds of
all kinds of names this is going to be a
whole park it's kind of like a wax
museum that he's got planned now except
i guess these are going to be
you know these are going to be
sculptures statues um
so kobe bryant humphrey bogart
miles davis charlton heston alfred
hitchcock
bob hope elvis presley jimmy stewart
ray charles nat king cole
um i i'm pretty sure christopher
columbus is going to be that george
washington
john adams thomas jefferson so we're
throwing some of them into martin luther
king jr jackie robinson amelia earhart
so it does seem like kind of a a random
assortment of people
but i like the idea my my only of course
my only
issue with with any statue or monument
project being undertaken right now
right before democrats take over is that
all that stuff is just going to come
down
but i'm in favor of just just keep
building the statues
and if this is what it comes to every
time we have a republican president just
build like
a thousand more statues just keep
building them
um all right number four
i wanted to play this for you just
because i thought it was very inspiring
um
i personally i was inspired for by it we
played yesterday camille harris
talking about her shoes and that also
was pretty inspiring but
uh here she is with some invigorating
words of encouragement
just for anyone out there she says she's
a she's kind of a motivational speaker
and she's a mentor
and these are her words of encouragement
i thought this was pretty great listen
i was raised to understand many people
will tell you
it is impossible but don't listen i
mentor a lot of people and i tell them
that there will be people who will say
it's not your turn it's not your time no
one like you has done it
and i'll tell them and don't you listen
and then i will go on to tell them i
eat no for breakfast
so authentic so authentic
just a parade of cliches
let's throw a bunch of cliches in a
blender you know
blend it up and pour it out and that's
that's what you have every time uh every
every time
camilla harris speaks i eat no for
breakfast do you really say that is that
really what you say to people
i hope you don't say that in real life
to people
in a normal conversation hey listen i
eat no for breakfast
you what why would you say that
uh but you know on the other hand i have
to
credit where it's due um camila harris
early on in her career to establish her
political career
it cannot be denied that
you know she she she took a very
hands-on approach
hands-on you know hands all kinds of
places i mean she really took a hands-on
approach
and she was going to get down and dirty
and really make sure that she uh that
she got her political career going and
i and i in that that much you do have to
respect that's all i'll say
by the way i just saw that sarah fuller
a kicker for vanderbilt
remember she was the you know the the
the woman they brought in to kick at
vanderbilt
she's going to be at the inauguration
apparently
which means there will be a person who
won the job
because of her gender despite a mediocre
performance
and also sarah fuller will be there so
that's going to be great number five
chicago prosecutors say that uh this is
from daily wire chicago prosecutors say
that 36 year old
adita singh lived in the city's o'hare
international airport for three months
to avoid flying home to los angeles amid
the chronovirus pandemic
this is one of those very strange
stories i've seen it everywhere and i
kind of assume we're going to find out
in a couple of weeks that half of this
is just wrong it didn't happen
because it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever um
cwb chicago which regularly covers the
city's bond hearings noticed
uh singh's case on sunday when singh
came up for
bond on charges of criminal trespass to
a restricted area and petty theft
apparently for continuing to use an
airport workers
misplaced credentials singh first
arrived to chicago on a flight from los
angeles on october 19th
and then he just decided to stay there
and he's been relying on other
passengers to provide him with food
shouldn't that i mean the moment you
have a panhandler in the airport
so you're telling me this guy was
panhandling in the airport
and it took him took people three months
to notice
an airport of all places with security
everywhere
i've because i've i've never seen that
i've never seen you see
in chicago you see panhandling
everywhere the only place you wouldn't
see it is in an airport so
i don't know i guess people just they
were going through chicago airport they
figure well this is part of the culture
here
um so he uh let's see he was using the
credential
and he i don't know we don't know where
he slept
or what he did my first question is why
o'hare of all places i can understand
spending a few months you know in maybe
the minneapolis airport or even
charlotte but o'hare chicago
the only good thing about o'hare is that
it's the one place in chicago where you
probably won't get shot
but other than that it doesn't have much
to recommend it
um as much as i kind of like airports
actually
good thing about airports you can drink
at 7am nobody judges you it's like the
one place in the world where you can do
that
that in a cruise ship i guess but that's
a strange story i guess
we'll have to keep our eyes on that to
see whether to see when the update comes
next week saying oh yeah you know
this never happened but for now we can
enjoy the story as it exists
before we get to our daily cancellation
you know we've been telling you for so
long about rockauto.com
and there's a reason for that because
it's it's just it's easy
it's affordable and it's the best thing
to do
if you need auto parts uh and how about
make this make this something you could
do this year
is uh just forget about going to the
auto parts store you don't need to do
that you can take that hassle
out of your life make your life a little
bit a little bit a little bit
a little a little more stress free and
take a little bit of the stress out of
your life
uh why not do that with rockauto.com
it's so much easier than walking into a
store
and having to answer all the questions
that they might be demanding of you and
you might not know all the answers right
away
and then what's going to happen a lot of
times they don't even have the part
you're looking for
they got to order it online and you can
just do that yourself because you have
access to rockauto.com at your desk and
in your pocket
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on
what the markets will bear like airlines
do why spend up to twice as much
for the same parts i ask you that i
demand an answer
if you can't answer it then go to
rockauto.com uh and the other great
thing is the family business they've
been serving auto part customers online
for 20 years you can go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low
if you see the price at rock auto you
know you can go and check somewhere else
if you want to go do that whole
rigmarole but you know you don't really
need to do that because if you see it
there
it's the best price you can you're gonna
get uh they're gonna get you they're
gonna give you the best price that is
possible
rockauto.com um really easy to navigate
and find those great prices amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your call will ever need
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right walsh in there how did you hear
about this box
so that they know that we sent you and
last thursday
was a big day for the daily wire we made
our entrance into the
entertainment space with a big feature
film run hide fight
and this is a movie is a tense exciting
very well made movie and that's what i
keep telling everyone
if you're worried about oh is this one
of those it's one of those typical
movies that you get from conservative
companies or it's just
the acting is pretty bad and the script
is bad
you just sort of endure it because you
feel like you're doing a it's almost
like an act of charity to watch the
movie
um and the answer is no that is not the
case with this movie it's a great script
great acting um and it just it's just
it's
it's escapism entertainment it wraps you
into the story
um and if you want to watch the movie um
you can become a member use promo code
rhf to get 25
off your membership that's rhf for 25
off as we keep reminding you this is not
a family movie okay this is a there's
violence in this movie it's an intense
film but at the same time and you know
it's also entertaining but there is
there is also a message there
they're not going to hit you over the
head with the message but there's a
message
for for adults you know it's not for
kids but it's for adults
we picked this movie movie up even after
hollywood refused to and
you can tell that it was worth it
because if you go to rottentomatoes.com
go to rotten tomatoes right now you're
going to see the critics are giving it
like a 14
rating but the audience is giving it
like 98
okay so you see that disparity that's
when you know a movie is good we're
excited to bring you great stories that
hollywood refuses
to tell and we hope you'll join us and
become a member today over at
dailywire.com
and remember you'll get 25 off when you
use promo code rhf so go watch the movie
now and let's get to our
daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be canceling someone who dispensed
some bad parenting advice on tick tock
really i suppose we should
just cancel all parenting advice that is
given on tick tock frankly i'm horrified
to discover that parenting advice on tic
tac
is even a thing but it is a thing
apparently and very much so our culprit
today has a tick tock account with a
hundred thousand followers
and the video we're gonna play in a
moment has seven million views and seven
hundred thousand likes
okay so the sad reality as much as we
might hate to admit it
is that a great many young people are
going to learn about parenting and get
their parenting wisdom and advice
from tick tock so it does matter that
the advice is
so abysmally stupid and also dangerous
so we'll go through this video
um it's less than a minute but uh but
here it is
and uh we'll we'll start here and we'll
discuss
why i don't use a crib for my five month
old if you look at a typical american
nursery
you will notice that it's set up for the
parents benefit not the child's
okay you're right that's true let's just
stop right there the nursery is for the
parents benefit in fact
everything in the house is for the
parents benefit in the sense that it's
all set up
how it's set up because the parents want
it that way and know they need it that
way
they also know their kids need it that
way even even if their kids don't
want it that way you know for up to my
kids we would be living
in refrigerator boxes outside defecating
in the yard
eating fast food for every meal yes i'm
teeing up for a san francisco joke here
but it's probably not necessary to spell
out the punchline
the point is the nursery the kitchen the
living room
living room everything in the house
they're all going to be set up to the
parent specifications for the benefit of
both the parent and the child
i cannot imagine what a nursery set up
to an infant specifications would look
like
because infants don't have
specifications because they're infants
okay let's get back to the clip the
artwork is usually up high where babies
can't even see it
we literally buy these little baby jail
cells so that we can just leave our baby
in there and walk away
well again yeah you know i wouldn't call
it a jail cell
that might be a bit traumatic but it is
certainly a huge benefit to be able to
put your baby down and walk away the
other option is to what never walk away
from your child ever i mean just
24 hours a day every day you you're
never in a different room
see this is how you know the young lady
here only has one child and only has
been a parent for a few months
and it's also why nobody with one kid
who is still who the kid is still a baby
should be giving any parenting advice at
all ever to anyone
if you're still at the point where
you're scandalized by the idea of a
parent putting their child down for a
minute and walking away
then you haven't been in this game long
enough you need a few more circles under
the eyes a little more drool and spit up
on the shoulder
a little dirt under the fingernails or
something under your fingernails
you hope it's dirt you never know when
there are kids in the house i can tell
you i can't tell you how many times as a
parent
i've been holding a child or even like
sitting in a chair or something and then
i look down and there's some sort of
ominous
substance on me and i think what the
hell is this
is this pudding please tell me this is
pudding who had pudding
anyway back to the video i don't have a
crib because i will never enforce my
baby to have a bedtime
babies are people too and forcing anyone
to sleep when they're not tired is
inhumane
imagine if your partner locked you in a
container you couldn't get out of and
told you you had to sleep even though
you weren't tired
that would be abuse and you'd probably
leave them kids deserve the right to
bodily autonomy just like we do
and that involves sleep okay many
problems here first your baby
is not your partner um that is a
very strange way of characterizing it
your baby is is
is not your partner in any sense at all
your baby is your baby and the thing
about your baby being your baby is that
he's a baby
as such he has no idea when he's tired
he has no idea when he needs to sleep
babies cry when they're tired okay it's
extremely irrational behavior i
i have i have turned to my kids when
they're crying
because they're tired and i have said
hey if you're tired just go to sleep
you're a baby don't you understand that
you could literally just lie on the
floor right now and sleep and nobody
would judge you
i can't do that i wish i could i can't
just pass out on the floor
what are you crying about i should be
the one crying you've kept me awake for
the past nine months i'm hallucinating
i'm literally gonna die you don't see me
crying
i've said this to our babies many times
but it's no use i've discovered
these are the lessons you learn with
parenting they can't be reasoned with
they don't understand anything they
don't know
that they're supposed to sleep when
they're tired you have to think about
that
this is how clueless kids are this is
your job as a parent
you have to teach them that you're
supposed to sleep when you're tired that
is not something that comes naturally
you have to give them that structure and
guidance
um you know my my 14 month old was was
fussy and tired the other day so
she she literally started this is what
she was doing she was tired she was
running in circles in the living room
periodically throwing herself on the
ground and crying
and at other points laughing
hysterically
this is the behavior of a lunatic but
she gets she gets a pass because she's
14 months old
that's why i had to pick her up put her
in the crib
and say okay bedtime so
forcing your child to sleep is one of
the best things you can do for them give
them structure get them on a schedule
make sure they're rested it's a very
good idea all right let's let's let's
finish this put ourselves out of our
misery
one last clip let's go this is our
current setup but we also have a floor
bed
the floor bed allows the baby to sleep
when the baby
is feeling sleepy and get up and move
around when the baby's not
my god get up and move around whenever
he wants
he's five months old what is he gonna do
walk out to the kitchen and fix himself
a sandwich in the middle of the night
don't mind me mom i'm just grabbing a
midnight snack
by the way please this is all joking
aside that and i i really mean this
everyone if you're if you're watching
the video you can see this this uh
image of the child as a parent of four
kids
this to me is one of the most terrifying
things i've ever looked at in my life
this picture right here
you tell me that's that's the bed of a
five-month-old
please do not put your babies in beds
with blankets and pillows and stuffed
animals
as this woman has apparently done i am
genuinely concerned for the child's
welfare
they can easily suffocate at that age
with that sort of stuff in their bed
do not do that i mean really you want
you want to be
i i'm maybe a little bit more paranoid
about uh about choking and
suffocation as a parent than i need to
be but
what i would say is you want to be well
into their first into their second year
of life
you want to be well past the one year
mark before you start putting them in
bed with any kind of blankets or pillows
or anything they don't need it
and at five months do not do that
do not do that they can get that stuff
gets wrapped around their head
and that's how that's how you get sids
that's how kids die in their sleep okay
it happens
so put your baby in a crib treat your
baby like a baby
because he is a baby uh that's what you
should do
basically do the opposite this is my
recommendation you could take it from
the guy with four kids or the
woman who's got who's had one kid for
five months uh
what i would say is do the opposite of
everything you just heard from our
friend in the video
all of that take all of that and just do
the the opposite of
that's a good way of being because for
now she is
canceled and i really hope to god
someone talk some sense into her
and soon and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show as joe
biden prepares to take office as
president of the united states
democrats push radical policies and
revenge and we ask whether a worse
authoritarian threat is actually around
the corner that's today on the ben
shapiro shall give it a listen